and I said if you got to hold them in
the fourth grade you got to hold them in
the fourth grade okay let's do the Shay
gene I think the kids sleeping come on
Randy let's go upstairs it's the bedroom
on the left
[Music]
Radio SiriusXM 95 I'm dead soda that's
me garrison this is music that your mom
gets banned babe our guests today from
the amigos podcast amigo the world's
amigo Mike for Noah and the our special
coming out Friday 11:00 p.m. on Comedy
Central called positive influence these
amarelle it's gonna be so good thanks so
good so goddamn good you will enjoy it
DVR right now you or I
will come to you with my new knife
collection and bring hell with it
I got excited me and Christine's
relationship is kind of span the time of
me watching guys like Sam mark Normand
and those guys that come through New
York and comments it's great to see you
guys who remember in the same class I
mean a little you were you were like
before them but to see these guys were I
was already kind of like looking at
weather I mean not looking back seeing
these guys who just caught my attention
for how funny they were and that cream
is rising the top man's
fantastic to see we started talking
earlier about post comedy I'm always
excited to get into it a value we tried
to drag any more specials by name and
anything but I don't know what the hell
everything's a new norm ecologist spoke
on this actually on Stern today was
pretty interesting is take one I love
what he says he goes I hope I mean I
wouldn't be surprised but I really hope
it I hope not I would be surprised
either but he uh you know it's it's
funny how fast they could turn
on you but he said on Stern today it was
a great line he goes well stars like
yeah well no I'm you kind of always
subscribe to you know comedy supposed to
just be funny it's not supposed to have
to make a point it's gonna be funny he
goes call me old-fashioned
this is a great like like definitive
line to make for that I don't understand
why these people who are like it's got
to be anti-authority it's got and you're
just like well some comics can just make
jokes yeah not everything has to have
you know why is another passage yeah
it's it's a weird thing where I think
all comedians are pushing back in a
certain way of like this kind of don't
tell us what to joke about right and
then now they're also saying like and
there's no jokes like don't joke around
about it's like you can't choose what
you're joking around about and don't
make it funny cuz it's there it just
seems to be a thing of outrage but gots
more outrage and they just can keep
stirring the pot and being like I'm
mad and it's like it's an it's a
it's an activity now to get mad about
that you read online it's like a
thing you can do it's like playing a
video game you're like I'm gonna go on
Twitter and get furious about
some and maybe take away someone's
job and it's like it's kind of
crazy I think a lot of comics
that I think are of course compounds it
because what he said is we christine has
pulled up an article that says nor make
a joke he made after the whole thing
yeah which I told you that's the one
joke I heard that Ryan back even like
text DM me to be like dude is hilarious
but nor McDonald said you know to not
think the meat to not think me to was
good he's like it I'd have to have down
syndrom and so that's like that's so he
was like defending the me to movement
but do it right then he didn't do it
right and I got points I didn't say the
r-word the actual medical term
yeah when discussing the trauma that
sexual abuse victims face mr. McDonald
said of course he understood the
consequences you went on to say you'd
have to have down syndrome my new word
my steez trigger up this is funny when
you break down hilarious people talking
like if they did this with or if they if
you wrote an article like our show like
they talked they shamed moms it's
like we were talking about our own moms
getting you know you know how
incredibly exposing that is to yourself
to be like yeah I remember these awful
comments that I'm laughing about at 35
with some of the best comics in the
world yeah I think eyes are super
self-deprecating and it's like
it all started with when comedy became
super personalized and when like the
story became bigger than the joke yeah I
don't mean when it could be like oh this
can go on for seven minutes with no
punchlines and then there's like one big
pop at the end you're like well that's
it that's not a bit that's that's a
different genre of comedy and it's cool
the comedies expanding but don't tell us
that it has to be this one thing
that's point four point my exact
argument about it's my problem with the
Nannette ah what do you know Hannah
Gatsby comments after that was you're
cutting out so many comics who I love by
saying that comedy has to have a much
greater point in like so Dave Attell
Brian Regan
character Shakera could gas millionaire
carrot top not be I know right not be in
comedy somehow I mean how do you argue
like but it's good for comedy that it's
broadening doors and everything is good
for coming it means it's being taken
more seriously it's good to have
different parts of comedy but don't tell
us it's like the most close-minded
people telling us a comedy has to be
this one thing there's also some people
that are sneaking into comedy and Tim
Dylan made this argument perfectly that
there's some unfunny people that are
trying to kneecap other people
to be like this is my thing you're out
yeah I can't do the thing you did I
couldn't be totally so now I can't be
funny so I'm a geek happier now my what
I do is funny like but it's the left in
order to break the rules you have to
know the rules
yes director and you're like no you got
to know how to make a good movie you
can't just make a shitty movie and be
like I did that on purpose even at some
point in their Norman Donald said he
goes you know it's not cut it's a
one-man show it's not a stand-up special
and he goes and those are I completely
respect those thank you being like
serious and like sentimental he's like
those are great I think the templates
that lead comedy channel well I think
when I was coming up the templates at
the time were very much a tell Dane Cook
yeah do you know I mean yeah you see
molds every man Marc Maron sort of had
that and like the alternative circuit
the kind of mold you kind of when you're
doing your creative character in a video
game where you start and my cursor
everyone was definitely in the vein of
like watching a towel and being like I I
don't even think Kurt I guess more so by
never even had my comedy was never in
the vein of a tells so much like setup
joke but it's in the voice of the style
of the genre a genre of is what I mean
but you're gonna be influenced by
someone who's much greater at it than
you are when you start of course but all
the templates used to at least if
nothing else
Marc Maron whoever you choose in that
vein Sarah Silverman for long little
girls Hedberg Louis all of them were
like there was no argument that it was
like funny you're not funny
the templates that people start
following start getting further away
from funny and falsely so is like a Doug
Stanhope that became a big template like
a generation behind me in comedy you
know it's crazy holds my generation and
I saw a lot of guys being like but
Stanhope pulls off it's this unique
thing he does and he's very very funny
the whole way through
and you'll come out a mistake funny for
like I'm gonna hammer home a point yeah
people don't want to hear like I just
you just go against the grain and then
walk offstage where he's going against
the grain and then making you laugh you
know there's where you're talking about
seeing coming up what I saw coming up is
you'd see guys that weren't funny that
we're doing the Stanhope and kind of
disguising not being funny under like
what you guys don't want to hear about
this my plans for abortion to Rio for
it's just not funny but norm
called it out too on Stern today's same
person I'd say kind of like at Stanhope
was the beginning of that the test with
the people put him to another like two
political comics there was like Lenny
Bruce and then more it's all and then
it's like everyone now would take
everyone's accused the problem with
Trump and it's true even to open mics
but John Stuart st. John Stewart was
yelling when the kind of subtly even he
wasn't doing stand-up necessarily know
he has a stand-up not doing stand-up
like that thing well I can't think like
kinda like that preach think but that's
a show it's a different format it's a
great joke but I agree with you but it's
like that there's that now like those
guys who are just doing the here's my
point though like couldn't handle it
can't the walking people and thinking
it's cool it's like no Bill Hicks would
go to Alabama and Arkansas and
kill what these liberal that's a that's
that that's the power of that he was
funny and he had like joke like jokes
watching back man and he was he was
taking it to them he was taken away
he wasn't as a makes you laugh with him
at the idea that he doesn't believe in
evolution that's a testament to how
funny someone can be with each
other than man it's totally credit
Tiana's papas in 2009 he goes do you
know who the most alternative comic in
New York City is Nate bargatze he's like
he's a southern but Joe Mackey yeah he's
a southern guy saying Walmart's great in
his Brooklyn rooms and they're like put
stuff back and you're like that's a
testament to great comedy is when like
Bill Burt like watching him explode I
remember going to his shows his live
show to Caroline's
he'd started thing we were like oh
this is what I don't agree or that and
then just by the end he's just hammering
home funny oh my god it's
hilarious be right Joe Mackey Paula yeah
yeah yeah but Mackey's like a guy who's
hilarious and if you sit and
talk to me like oh we don't have our
morals do not go take a shower
Ryan Hamilton's not a guy we are like
this is clean comedy you just watch the
next guys hilarious
I didn't cuss once but it doesn't mean
it's better or worse it just means he's
super fun yeah so to take the
funny out of it I think is like it's
it's I don't know do you think it's a
template now is just I think the temples
people are look there's looking to the
wrong templates now because do you want
to make headlines over yeah do you know
I mean they're being like ice creams not
gonna be sweet anymore okay I'm not
saying anyone's long about anything but
you can get a legit chance for a career
bump if you say somebody harass
if you like a young comic girl comic you
say somebody with power did something to
you you can get a BA you can get it you
get a momentary minute in the spotlight
to try to bump and I think some people
do that for sure which I think I always
hate dicks it trivializes real victims
of
yeah like the people that use it well
that's what Joe Mackay molested me yeah
that's a huge thing I told you I was
watching Bill Maher today the Jim Carrey
was just on yeah the end of it here he
goes no he's like defending our Franken
which I'm not even against
fending out Franken but it's just Louis
I said it's too outside it's so funny
like Al Franken there's a picture of him
doing that's the joke picture of him
squeezing the girls tits I don't think
it's a major deal but to us out it's all
about sex and if the girl did have a
problem then he should have done that
and whatever the people are saying is
least it's a lot of like how Franken
accusations are like he really squeeze
is pretty tight when he puts his arm
around your waist for a picture it's
like okay so Bill Maher's lobbying like
well listen I believe Al Franken so I
believe believe your friends I think we
should come back and run for something
and I know and I go at the same time
really if your major sticking point of
trumps thing like what piece of he
is in that regard he said to another
dude that he thought the cameras were
off you can just touch a chick's
when you're famous man they love
it that's really what he did you know I
mean and I'm gonna fan of Trump get him
in office tomorrow I don't give a
like you made it you made a point after
that that it's like it's like when
you're dating someone this was the point
because you like eventually people's
wives at one point someone's husband or
wife was their boyfriend or girlfriend
and you had a dirty conversation with
your friend about that person really
like a champ dude and it's and
then like two years later like that's my
son's mother you told me that
she deep throated you on the second day
like that was a good day early me and
Christine dating Dean Edwards me were
standing outside of a comedy club
Christine came out and walked back in
and he looked at Christine from the back
and he looked at me with like he didn't
know how I was dating her yeah and he
goes myself a scan me to say something
so you want to give him that like like I
said I mean he goes oh nice now so he
had to she throws it down good friend
interception women do that I mean that's
that's across the board right yeah like
then we told a girl about yeah how I
or something about it why not yeah
I don't know if it changes so much from
like a guy you're dating like that's my
husband
women are more territorial but I think
over time you you discuss less both
sexes discuss less sexually yeah about
their partners with their friends and
also nobody wants to hear about the
you're having with your wife yeah I said
I wanted to make a joke about that every
every every perfect family you see with
the husband wife you love each other and
three kids and it's 12
yeah at some point that guy went to one
of his buddies looks like do that during
a girl I went out takes it to
the balls dude I think she I've never
seen a girl take them pretty impressive
five years she's the strongest woman
I've ever met that's why I saw her go
through that delivery rooms changed my
that's my hero monster Bill Maher think
I'm just he's coming out for Al Franken
in defense Al Franken it's just like
yeah it's like your buddy your coffee
for your buddy everything so ok liberals
if you want to write off Al Franken
I'll thought again oh my god the best
he's hilarious but it everything so
bipartisan now that it that doesn't
matter anymore you know what I mean like
he's on that team so Bill Maher's on
that team that's like I'm defending that
if Trump was on his team he would defend
that that's just what it is now
it's so split it's laughable but
that's that bipartisan that's everything
there's also shitty once people defend
someone and then like with norm it's
like well even if you don't agree with
him which I'm sure most people don't
based on this I mean to just a right I
don't like the erasing of people I don't
like that you're now banned from this
show yeah here now Natalie it's such mob
even the positive - and they go
back to this kind of touches on that a
little bit just this idea of like like
we banish people now when they up
for good I've been saying it's like it
feels like now culture is like figure
skating routine like you fall down like
you're
but he wrote what you highlighted Norma
Colin said I meet I mean all kinds of
women that have terrible stories about
what happened to him McDonald said I
wasn't talking about the victims they
asked me about Roseann they asked me
about Chris Hardwick he asked me about
Louie and I told them you know if
someone murders someone you know and
goes to jail right and then and then he
gets out of jail after ten years and you
go I'm gonna give this guy a job washing
dishes because he's done his penance
nobody goes well what about the people
he murdered well of course they had it
off worse I was turning to him Mulaney
at the end I upon try to keep it
McDonald but it moved into a Mulaney
know look he makes a good point and they
said they asked him about something
specific and I don't think they spun his
words necessarily I just mean what I'm
saying people now because of how
comfortable we live it's it's an
activity to get furious on
totally you can I can choose right now
to go online and find something that
makes me angry under tipping a
you know ya know addictive I
mean the big thing again I think a lot
of comics great ones and I think me
personally floating like the gray area
of the world like seeing the ridiculous
on both sides on all but it's not that
with most of the world need you to like
pick this that's my anymore so
one makes me hate like or want to not
like the other thing how much I'm just
inundated with anti-trump yeah I
know he saw I wish I me
I wish Obama could just be president
again tomorrow just because like
everybody just be happy now and like
shut up yeah but it's the way they talk
about goes we had an amazing president
who got the world back on track and I'm
like I bet if you do if I was a politics
person who dug deep I bet there's plenty
of Obama policies of the suck
nothing to do with his black or white
just heap up but he's knows how to
get on this thing he did that speech was
it lay at the end of last week he's the
best it was amazing guys like
smooth jazz the calms you down but he
didn't say also Trump is like a
professional troll so it's like what
hate him is just gonna you're just gonna
keep hating before
the thing you're doing the thing he
wants you to do yeah when he's being
like you're stupid he goes Jim Carrey
pretty smart thing he actually did say
of all the goofy Jim Carrey he does
I think he said on
that's what hundreds of millions of
dollar two decades of hundred millions
of dollars in something happened Jim
Carrey Jim Carrey came out four forces
said he came out wearing like Nikes
making him a big Colin Kapernick thing
whatever but then he goes uh he's like
lobbying I talked to Dave Smith about
this and his funny he's he's lobbying
for socialism in a country that
capitalism has made him a bazillionaire
yeah and I'm certain but they've said
the music I'm certain he hasn't given up
two hundred million dollars I'm sure he
hasn't given one hundred ninety nine
million to like charity and good faith
hey I need a little bit to live off
people were looking to be angry and you
can be angry calling all the celebrities
and he told me Dave Smith told me do
that Bill burr as a joke I don't think
I've ever heard made me laugh about all
this made me not like watching Alec
Baldwin's stuff even if he's funny yeah
because he was just one of the guys like
if Trump wins I'm moving to Canada say
well that's not anything impressive
thing to say like so you're gonna go
live in a mansion congratulations I
don't give a Phil Collins lives in
Switzerland I don't give a like
into Fallujah it's like you're moving
the nice country yeah it was a
nice place you guys keep playing this
way and I'm gonna move to a nice 17th
century Victorian he said Bill burrs got
a joke he goes how narcissistic to even
announce that to the world
yeah do do you think we someone's get me
to pull that lever he goes I want to
vote for Trump but I don't want to lose
share
Alec Baldwin's gonna move what if Jim
Carrey goes back to Canada it's so weird
man because it's like this is a symptom
of comedy being very popular it's like
there's a lot of money involved now so
people are making money in different
ways in some ways that people have found
money one of my favorite people to watch
if you are bored and you have Instagram
follow Michael che che thinks and watch
his posts about comedy bloggers that he
calls Meghan Meghan's I love it and it's
one it's one of its some of the funniest
reading because he just proves time and
time again he's like there's people just
out there just to say they hate
just so people will click just so that
other other websites will share their
clickbait yeah and he just like points
it out in such a way that it's so
funny that it is it's it's an
interesting to watch because him now
commenting is an activity the way them
getting mad about comedies and activity
so it just feeds on yourself it's this
weird incestuous like okay now I can
watch this person get mad about this and
what's this person's opinion about this
person getting mad
taking toward her off my phone greatest
thing in the world that bet yes Ari
Shaffir follows no one and it's got like
hundreds of thousands of followers but
I'm so like jealous of him so he's like
the smartphone he's never who's got a
flip phone but it really is the thing
where it's you when you get off like is
this like a blog about it this were the
screenshots from him where he it was
right after he defended Louie and then
he was posting other blogs yeah how
reckless he is you know for his fame
with the status that's what always like
I live in a partisan deep legion
of skanks and STR episodes check but she
goes for it never gets in trouble oh
I'll tell you this funny he's funny it's
just ever and ever a whiff of
hack he's a great comic yes but I think
that's also what you're seeing is and
that's back to that Tim Dylan argument
works like a lot of unfunny people
trying to take down being like wow these
guys funny I got a I got a shot and I'm
not talking about everybody I'm talking
about malicious people that are in this
biz hound Criers who don't write
jokes who like we just have to be like
oh they're funny I guess
yeah as I was saying you but it's been
Reuven if you make some allegation
you'll get your moment to possibly pop
and breakthrough you know I mean well
get your shot but it won't be it won't
be a long-lasting shot like it's funny
who I talked to especially like across
the board I'm not talking about just
white dudes I'm talking about like when
I talked to Michelle wolf or like Marina
Franklin and you talk to these people
and like it's and they're like
oh yeah there's a lot of around
here right now yeah there's a lot of a
lot of this is filled with murk
and that's like this is look
for whatever you think of the specialty
of him like drew Michaels says pretty
early this thing about like this
disability that words like so it has to
separate himself I'm a straight white
man but I have a hearing thing yeah the
guy that's how far it's gone who's
wailing it stigma yeah but you have to
agree how important that isn't that
special for what he's trying to a
straight white but I there are some
colors I can't make itis it's been the
guy who is murdering on America's Got
Talent
I mean walking his way to the finals
yeah is a guy who has Tourette's okay
his eye blinks a little bit and that's
every joke is about it and they standing
ovations them every single time never
heard but I mean it is this it's so
direct it's so direct to like play it
just enjoy you Heidi Sorry Sorry
does he hit pause it pause it pause it
your shows looks great I hear a slight
wigger accent I'd say it's fat black
southern mama voice for some reason like
he's got waffles in the back it sounds
like Cleveland a little bit okay
recently oh yeah what's up girl
Oh totally well this guy's only black
sir he has jokes jokes about being at
like black house parties and the cops
come and think he's like fill in the
blank go Dan what do you do are this
with Christine's favorite game watch me
do ya
as we said watches he goes the cops come
in a party in there go and I go just
pause it
all you okay do you need some help let
me keep my friend and that's like and
just hit play and watch it happen
exactly like I said I'm not sure I say
this you probably saw cuz you lived with
them but Sam it's a legitimate time to
like he'll know a hacky premise and
finish the joke in a way that you're
like that's crazy
I did them all on super 8 tape in
between my mom stitches between that
it's my mom I'm stools and
oh my god oh you know FUBU sure pumping
the stage but it is one of those talents
it's like crossword puzzle it's amazing
I'm not I can get the easy ones but J's
like 19 down yeah you nail him I
remember you tell me that you and J
would go to like Governors and see like
just okay it was various president to
say the name if you didn't make Canada
special on this show oh don't we broke
down his lady's special on the show
Pete Davidson got us tickets yeah he was
before the gun shaped microphone era of
Nick Cannon but yeah just so you know
what you talk about like jumping in on
it but he is like a guy that went from
being like man I'm so rich show business
is so awesome to be like I'm woke what's
all this problem what it was
like almost by the next special you're
like that much of a character ship like
if I do my next special and it's all
about like communism and socialism
what is so dirty I'm like let me tell
you the problems the all right so
they're special
all right I'm sorry murder cuz that I
knew is gone bring back monster monster
truck by a calm more like vaya con the
con and you America to believe and
comedy central's funny dude that's all
that's all left and for just alt Dan I
don't know it's like the terminator
scene where he's in the lava melting in
a different people
always there why don't you make
illegal immigrants CEOs of companies
doose's you just go you go thoughts
pause screen coming to a man cotton
audience member I need an audience
member to beatbox am i close up in the
sky
if anybody says they have crazy thoughts
in their comedy special get the turn off
yeah get the funds going right off
what if you do though you go I'm
schizophrenic followed by actual crazy
shitty half joke hero I goes um I got
just nutty thoughts man going through my
head all the time it's like I just look
at christine's sleep in there next to me
I'm like I got just Joker in the sleep I
can put a pillow over her face and Oh
she'll never be able to start nutty
thoughts she kill a dog monkey up sweets
I'm so loco off I'll take a I'll
look at it and I'll go should I eat that
bitch I eat that for a half hour
I'll have this all in my head I'll take
a cold shower with my clothes on
and I go if I could suck a ghost stick
would I do it crazy though
you